so mr. Donnelly you only explore places in America
that's right I am an American Explorer why won't
you go to a foreign country because I think
that's carrying a joke too far scenery the
old world is very beautiful and the people are
very quaint yes Messina in America's just as
pretty and the people are just as funny I prove
it how come with me and we'll explore the island
of Manhattan ok this is a panoramic view of the
extreme southern end of the island of Manhattan
it was settled by the Dutch in 1624 just thirty
families now it has a population of almost two
million later the Isle of Manhattan is thirteen
and a half miles long and two and a half miles
wide that statue marks the exact spot where Peter
Minuit fought the entire island from the Indians
for 60 guilders and to bottle Silver's [ __ ]
today the natives would give the island back
to the Indians for two bottles of the same kind
of whiskey the section known as the bastard it
is called the battery because it is here the
immigrants get their free shot their second
shot comes when they see in here the native let's
look at some of these later no they do have ties
Manhattan Island's favorite native lived in this
house it was here he first said radio you're
right advancement house this is not a cheese
box if the aquarium it was formally canceled
Artie where the immigrants were originally kept
it is still filled with queer looking fish look
there goes a school of little mini all the day
long poor fish streaming here to see the other
sucker let me show you where they really hook this
sucker here it is folks Wall Street the fishing
isn't so good right now the natives ran out of
bait you can see for yourself I'll cook at this
street is the building to your right is the office
of JP Morgan could he would be on the right side
of the street Morgan's no fool here's one man on
Wall Street whose business is open and aboveboard
across the street from mr. Morgan where he can
keep one eye on it is the United States Treasury
Building you're not allowed to walk out of here
with any of their samples the statue of George
Washington marks the spot where Washington was
inducted into office as the first president of
the United States Morgan's private offices just
around the corner where mr. Morgan can keep his
other eye busy is the world famous Stock Exchange
this is a very powerful building no wonder it's
full of steel some time ago members Tate as
high as $600,000 for seats on this exchange
now they're looking for seats in the park most
of them have lost their seats and all of them
have lost their standing safe-deposit company
you tell one the place where Washington said
goodbye to his officers before taking his seat
at present it's frogs his tavern built in 1700
the tavern is still a popular resort with an
antique furniture and Aksarben costumes as is
were in the Revolutionary days when in Manhattan
you should visit the Holland Tunnel this marvelous
bit of engineering costs fifty million dollars
the tunnel ones under the Hudson River and is a
mile and a quarter long 30 thousand cars drive
through every 24 hours the toll is $0.50 a car
here is the birthplace and home of Manhattan's
most famous native Theodore oh stop even to this
day the air inside this historic house seems to
be charged with the dynamic personality of the
beloved Teddy the much talked of Tammany Hall it
was founded in 1786 by st. Tammany an Indian chief
whose slogan was peace at any cost the Irish shall
now control Tammany still believe in peace at any
cost even if they have to fight to get it the hall
or wigwams keep business is scalping Republicans
while the Republicans do not trust Tammany the
manufacturers do as you can see Tammany Hall is
the political headquarters of the island this is
City Hall the hind quarters you remember it was
Nathan Hale who said just before he was hanging
I regret I have only one life to give for my
country well this slaughterhouse is built on the
site where that great American Hero was executed
such as fate and faith 5th Avenue here we see the
finest stores and shops in the world as well as
the loveliest women it's here me lady by surfers
me monk dunk and skunk on Fifth Avenue you'll see
everything from the tallest structure on earth
to this funny-looking fellow on the horse he's
an up-to-date Paul Revere he dashes through
the streets on a brewery horse shouting beer
is here yah whoa what the well-dressed horseman
should not wear the natives Frank this island
greatest city in the world what you can see for
yourself it's just a one-horse town the Public
Library it is one of the finest buildings of its
kind in the world the natives of Manhattan spent
millions of dollars on this building filling
it with rare additions but the rarest edition
you'll find in the library is a Manhattan made
it it's a common sight to see a man walk down
those steps happy with the knowledge he has
gained only to get hit with a taxi because
he was too dumb to know the traffic laws I don't
know what those two Lions represent maybe they're
booked in should you find the book that is too
complicated or involved you can stand here and
read between the lines now at last we arrive on
the Great White Way the street that is paved with
tears and laughter Broadway for every light there
is a broken bulb in any of these nightclubs the
Hat girl takes your hat but the club takes your
shirt here's where you will find your favorite
actor or radio crooner they claim prosperity is
just around the crooner there are more picture
palaces and theaters here than any other Street
on earth water stream even the firemen are going
to blazes or maybe they're just calling on an old
flame you are now looking up Park Avenue where the
rich and Ritchie natives live on this street will
be found the finest apartment houses on the island
they build houses very quickly here on Monday
they lay the foundation and the following Monday
they're putting out the tenants for not paying
their back rent you have just seen Manhattan's
richest street well now you're looking at its
poorest this is the famous Bowery the street
of bread lines keep hotels and flop houses here
is a striking example Sylvan ears for all this
fellows leaving with some of the souvenirs he
says some of the biggest bugs in town live here
here is a real point of interest a place you
must see while in Manhattan grants to everybody
who ever visited this island has seen this to
everybody what grant that plain old-fashioned
house between the two modern buildings what's
the home of Alexander Hamilton America's greatest
treasure p.m. before Mellon follow the colored
section and we're lucky to get all the Amos and
Andy's and Madame Queens and Ruby Taylor strutting
their stuff my but the Gold Dust twins have grown
from the size of this fella that he must be the
head man huh ain't that something now who's this
well shut my mouth if it ain't hit Montgomery
wind el the deficiency expert this is the
Harlem of northern end of the island of
Manhattan and the end of this exploration